this is the monduo pro Duo display the
best triple display setup for your
16-inch MacBook Pro and no not only
because it's the world's first setup
designed for the 16 inch but for five
very specific reasons now I have to be
honest I was skeptical about using a
triple display setup that mounts to your
MacBook and that is where David the guy
who designed all of this because he
loves MacBook Pros actually went out and
he just sent one us without us even
knowing and when I opened up the box
like huh what is this and then I started
reading the specs and it was really
impressed he then sent us an email
letting us know he sent it out and you
know just try it out check it out for
yourself and that's why I realized well
I was kind of wrong with my
misconceptions now there are other
monitors on the market with setups like
this but they have a lot of issues the
displays are very low quality the build
quality is janky they just don't pair up
with your max display and that is the
second part that really impresses these
dual displays have 500 nits of
brightness just like the MacBook Pro in
normal mode they also support DCI P3
color accuracy just like the MacBook
Pro's display they also are high refresh
rate so they go up to 144 Hertz now you
can use this with anything they have
multiple different plug-in options we
have dual USB type C's on each side
along with HDMI so you can use this with
Windows or with anything else and with
the MacBook I'm running these at 120
hertz just like promotion and with that
they are high resolution as well we have
2560 by 1600 resolution and so they are
nice and sharp so these panels match up
very well with the MacBook compared to
other Alternatives that are low
brightness low quality very low
resolution and refresh rates that don't
match up now before I give you guys the
other reasons why I was very impressed I
have to talk about my kind of issue with
setups like this when I've seen them in
the past they were very clunky so I was
hesitant one packing this with me on the
go and two with setup and adjustment now
you guys could see I'm not in the studio
I'm actually working remoli right now
and that's when I thought it was a
perfect scenario to take this with me
and test it out now setting this thing
up is way easier than I expected on my
third time ever setting it up I did so
in about 4 40 seconds it fits in my
backpack so I just slide it in next to
my laptop all I need is two cables to
take with me and then when I pull
everything out it literally takes I
don't know 30 seconds or so to open it
up pull the sides apart set it up
there's this built-in kickstand that
will add support to your display if it
needs that and simply plugging in the
two USB type c cables into the side now
the 16 inch MacBook Pro also has an HDMI
so you can connect with that the beauty
of USB type-c though is that it not only
sends the signal to the displays but it
Powers them at the same time so now I'm
completely wireless now they also give
you a right angle USB type-c adapter for
convenience and another cable if you're
not going to be using Mac safe charging
to charge up your laptop that you can
use for pass-through charging through
the display so send power back up to 100
Watts which is awesome and even running
both displays at 120 hertz I was
surprised by how little power they
sucked from the macbook's internal
battery now with that said before I show
you the software which is really sweet
it was developed for these screens I
want to answer the question is it really
useful now this is where I was also
hesitant you know you have the extra
displays there on the sides I'm used to
having a single display at the office I
have that 32 inch 6K display and when
I'm on the go I take a 16 inch MacBook
Pro specifically because of the larger
display compared to the 14 inch MacBook
or the 13 inch ones now having these
displays on the sides makes a world of a
difference in terms of on the grow
productivity instead of having to flip
between my final cut application and
then going to my finder going to the
internet when I need to pull up some
specifications I can have all of that
available and with that with video
editing I can have my viewer off to the
side which gives me a lot more room for
my timeline to be stretched out and
seeing other clips and images when I was
for example working on this latest blind
camera comparison if you guys didn't see
that go and check it out so that was so
nice to have I have the same level of
productivity as on that 32 inch pro
display xdr or maybe even slightly
better while I'm on the go and this
thing is surprisingly lightweight like I
said the plastic is high quality but it
is surprisingly lightweight so when you
put it in your backpack it doesn't add a
ton of extra bulk or weight now if you
don't do photo editing or video editing
just being able to have emails open on
one side spreadsheets or web-based
application open in the center and then
something else on the side is also
really nice to have and you can also do
7K gaming with this now I'm not gaming
on the go when I'm not working I'm
spending time with family but they've
shown on off some very cool clips of
having all three displays being used for
games running on the Mac or on a Windows
based laptop now one issue using
external displays with Max is scaling
and high DPI because there are very
limited settings and then things can
look fuzzy because they're not scaled
properly and this is where the mon Duo
app comes in it is a simple tool it
gives you a ton of settings now a lot of
these are enabled by default for example
these will auto match the brightness to
your Mac display so you're using the
buttons and everything matches up
perfect quickly it will auto match the
resolution to your built-in display auto
arrange and I'm unable to turn off Mondo
backlighting if you go ahead and you Dim
down your main screen all the way they
also make it super easy to install the
drivers for the displays and because of
that everything looks great and matches
up and it just works now here we have
advanced settings and we have an app
menu where you have a lot of different
options so if I go out here click on the
Mong Duo app we have all our info here
where you can go make other adjustments
and you can adjust your scaling but out
of the box everything just works now
this one is designed for the 16 inch now
these are LCD panels and even though
everything looks great they are not mini
LED well Mandu is working on a mini LED
version for those of you guys that want
all of your displays to be mini LED for
me personally I can have my HDR video
viewer on the main screen and the other
things on the side so it's not a big
deal but that is going to be coming out
if you want to ultimatch and for those
of you guys that love the 14 inch size
it's great to travel with well they're
working on a 14 inch version as well and
then that way I would be able to get a
smaller one to travel with and then have
the displays when I need it so we have
all the links down in the description
below you guys can actually save 50
bucks if you go through my link if you
guys want to go and check that out and
you can get more info on the future
products as well so overall I think this
is a killer solution I'm glad that David
sent it over I'm glad I got to check it
out and I'm glad that I was wrong about
having triple screens on a Mac because
being here for a while it's going to be
extremely useful based on what I've used
them already for so thank you guys for
watching you guys can go check out the
links right over there and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]